- Trump's secret documents
versus Hillary's emails.
Lock her up.
No, lock him up.
Lock them up?
Former President Trump has
been fighting to contain
and fundraise from the political fallout
after the FBI executed a search warrant
at his residence at Mar-a-Lago.
We have since learned that agents sought
to recover classified
documents being stored on site,
including confidential documents relating
to nuclear weapons or energy.
Among the items seized by FBI
agents were at least 11 sets
of classified documents,
four marked top secret,
three marked as secret, and
three marked as confidential,
the lowest level of
classified information.
After the warrant was unsealed,
or at least parts of it,
we learned that the FBI is
investigating the former
president for potential
criminal violations
of the Espionage Act, obstruction
and destruction of records.
- Were they looking for
the Hillary Clinton emails
that were deleted, but
they are around someplace?
- In response, several of
the ex-presidents defenders
in Congress have seamlessly
flipped from back the blue
to defund the FBI.
Other allies have opted to
invoke their favorite defensive,
all things Trump, but her emails,
and by her, I mean Hillary Clinton,
whose use of a private email server
while serving as Secretary of State,
resulted in multiple
investigations into her handling
of classified information,
and many of Trump's defenders have claimed
that he is a target of a double standard
and a political witch hunt
compared to Hillary Clinton.
Senator Lindsay Graham even
went on to Fox News to suggest
that prosecuting Trump while
not prosecuting Clinton
would result in massive rioting.
- If there's a prosecution of Donald Trump
for mishandling classified information
after the Clinton debacle,
which you presided over
and did a hell of a good job,
there'll be riots in the streets.
- Now at least facially, this
comparison doesn't seem crazy.
So let's compare the investigations
into Hillary Clinton's
private email server
with the FBI's seizure of
Donald Trump's top secret
documents at Mar-a-Lago and address
whether Clinton received
preferential treatment compared
to the former president
when it comes to handling
of classified material.
So what was that whole scandal about?
Well, in January, 2009, Clinton aids set
up an email domain called Clintonemail.com
on a private server located at
her Chappaqua, New York home.
While running the State Department,
Clinton exclusively used
email addresses connected
to that private server for
both work and personal emails,
rather than using a state.gov
email for government work
and a separate private account
for her personal affairs.
In May of 2014, the House
of Representatives voted
to create a select committee
to investigate the 2012 terrorist attack
on government facilities
in Benghazi, Libya
that killed four Americans,
including Ambassador, Chris
Stevens, and on March 2nd, 2015,
Clinton's private email
server became a national story
when the New York Times
ran a front page article
on the subject.
The article detailed
that the system, quote,
"may have violated federal requirements,"
and was characterized
as alarming by current
and former government archive officials.
Clinton claims she set up
her own email for convenience
so she would only need
to carry one smartphone
with one email rather
than two devices for work
and personal affairs,
but skeptics believe the
more likely explanation was
that Clinton, who was gearing
up to run for president,
wanted to be the sole arbiter
of what emails were personal
and what emails were government business
that needed to be turned
over in response to freedom
of information requests and
congressional inquiries,
and Clinton's team did decide on their own
what emails needed to be
preserved and which did not,
igniting a firestorm from
critics that exist to this day,
and on March 10th, 2015,
Clinton's office disclosed
that she kept 30,490 work related emails
and deleted approximately 31,830 emails
that she had deemed personal,
which she described as
communications about private matters
like yoga routines,
her daughter's wedding,
and her mother's funeral.
However, it turns out those
emails had only been intended
to have been deleted and had
not actually been deleted
until three weeks after
Congress subpoenaed Clinton's
Benghazi related emails,
and back in December, 2014,
Clinton's former Chief
of Staff, Cheryl Mills,
had told Plat River Networks,
the company that was
managing the private server,
that Clinton, quote, "decided
she no longer needed access
"to any of her emails older than 60 days."
Mills instructed an
unidentified PRN employee
to modify the email retention
policy to reflect this change.
However, the PRN employee
mistakenly did not implement
this change and did not
delete the old emails
when requested.
Sometime between March
25th and 31st, 2015,
this employee erased the emails
using a free utility program
called BleachBit.
Clinton later told the
FBI that she was not aware
that the emails were
deleted in late March, 2015,
and a Clinton campaign spokesman claimed
that the PRN employee was
advised to retain all data
in compliance with the
congressional subpoena
but acted on his own to complete
the prior deletion request.
In September, 2015, investigators
with the FBI were able
to recover some of the deleted emails.
Clinton's critics have
accused her and her aids
of deleting emails that
were under subpoena
to cover up wrongdoing.
Of course, during the
campaign, chants of lock her up
were regular features at Trump rallies
while Trump, himself,
famously invited Russia
to hack Hillary Clinton's server
to find the deleted emails.
- Russia, if you're listening,
I hope you are able to
find the 30,000 emails
that are missing.
I think you will probably be
rewarded mightily by our press.
- But in July, 2015, Inspectors General
at the State Department and the Director
of National Intelligence
asked the DOJ to review
whether classified
information was compromised
by Clinton's use of private email.
The following month, it
was confirmed the FBI
was investigating whether Clinton
or her staff violated federal
laws governing classified
information and whether foreign powers
or hostile actors had
hacked the private server.
The FBI investigated Clinton
under three criminal statutes,
18 U.S.C. 793, which makes it a felony
to mishandled classified
information in an intentional
or a grossly negligent
way, 18 U.S.C. 1924,
which makes it a misdemeanor
to knowingly remove classified
information from appropriate
systems or storage facilities,
and 18 U.S.C. 2071, which
makes it illegal to willfully
and unlawfully conceal, remove,
or destroy federal records,
and on July 5th, 2016,
FBI Director, James Comey,
held a press conference
announcing the department's
conclusion that no reasonable prosecutor
would bring a criminal case
against the former Secretary
of State due to lack of
requisite criminal intent.
Nevertheless, Comey also
famously remarked that Clinton
and her aids were, quote,
"extremely careless
"in their handling of very sensitive,
"highly classified information,"
and on October 28th, 2016, 11
days before the election day,
Comey announced the FBI
was reviewing new emails
that could be relevant to the
probe of Clinton's server.
The emails were being examined as part
of the FBI's investigation
into disgraced former
Congressman, Anthony Wiener,
who was the estranged
husband of Top Clinton aid,
Huma Abedin.
In a November 6th, 2016
letter to lawmakers,
Comey announced his agency's
review of emails was complete,
and it did not alter
the previous conclusion
that Clinton should not be prosecuted.
Two days later, Clinton was
defeated by Donald Trump
in the presidential election,
and while there are conflicting
accounts of the emails
at issue, it seems that of the
tens of thousands of emails
that were reviewed, 113 were found
to contain classified information
and only three of those
had classification markers,
65 of those emails were deemed secret,
and 22 deemed top secret.
In 2016, Comey said that Clinton
should have known that some
of those 113 were classified
but noted that there
were others that she might
have understandably missed.
On June 14th, 2018, the DOJs office
of Inspector General
released a report on the FBI
and DOJ's handling of the
Clinton investigation.
The report found no
evidence of political bias
and reaffirmed the decision
not to prosecute Clinton,
and in September, 2019,
a three year State Department
investigation concluded
that 38 current and former
State Department officials
were culpable in 91 cases of
sending classified information
that ended up in Clinton's email server.
Though the report stated that
the private email increased
the vulnerability of
classified information,
investigators found, quote,
"No persuasive evidence
"of systemic deliberate mishandling
"of classified information."
But let's compare that
to what we know right now
about the Trump Mar-a-Lago
scandal, which, admittedly,
is absolutely not complete
information at this time,
but after the FBI
executed a search warrant
on Donald Trump's Mar-a-Lago estate,
the former president posted a statement
on a social media platform,
Truth Social, attacking,
what he called the, quote,
"weaponization of the justice system,"
calling the search, "political targeting
"at the highest level."
Trump claimed that there
was a double standard with
how the FBI handled Hillary
Clinton's email investigation,
quote, "Hillary Clinton
was allowed to delete
"and acid wash 33,000 emails
after they were subpoenaed
"by Congress.
"Absolutely nothing has happened
to hold her accountable."
Now, putting aside that Clinton
did not literally cover the
server in bleach, obviously,
you take that internally
to fight covid, Trump and his
allies have long suggested
that Hillary Clinton should
have been prosecuted,
or at least, at a minimum,
prosecuting Trump would be unfair
of the double standard
created for Clinton,
but the use of private emails
and other unofficial communications
for government employees
has come up more often
than you'd think with varying
degrees of uproar and concern,
and though that certainly doesn't
excuse Clinton's behavior,
it's probably important to look
at other context and comparisons.
Among those who recently
used private email accounts
to conduct official government business
in the Trump administration,
that includes Advisor,
Steven Miller, former Chief
of Staff, Reince Preibus,
former National Economic
Council Director, Gary Cohn,
former Deputy National Security Advisor,
K. T. McFarland, and former
Advisor, Steve Bannon.
Trump's son-in-law, Jared
Kushner, and daughter,
Ivanka Trump, both presidential advisors,
used either personal email
accounts or the messaging app,
WhatsApp, to conduct official business,
and since WhatsApp messages are encrypted,
there's no record of
the message unless Jared
and Ivanka actually stored
copies of those messages.
Kushner's lawyer said his client, quote,
"took images of
communications from WhatsApp
"and forwarded them to official accounts,"
but when asked if Kushner used the app
to share classified information,
his attorney diverted saying, quote,
"That's above my pay grade."
Former White House Trade
Advisor, Peter Navarro,
also fighting contempt charges
for refusing to testify
to the January 6th committee,
is currently embroiled
in his own presidential record dispute
with the National Archives.
In August, 2022, the DOJ sued
Navarro claiming he refused
to turn over emails retained
on a private account
while working for the
Trump administration,
and even Colin Powell, who
served as Secretary of State
under George W. Bush from 2001 to 2005,
acknowledged using a
laptop on a private line
for State Department business
including sending notes
to ambassadors and foreign
ministers via personal email,
and in a January, 2009 email
exchange with Hillary Clinton,
Powell told incoming Secretary of State
that he used a private phone
and computer to do business
with foreign leaders and communicate
with senior department officials
on their own personal email accounts.
While Powell said that
Clinton was not influenced
by his email with
respect to setting her up
on her own server, he
also said he was, quote,
"not aware at the time of any requirement
"for private unclassified exchanges
"to be treated as official records."
But again, to emphasize, this is all bad.
It's a problem in Washington,
whether it's Hillary Clinton
or anyone else doing it.
Now, before we get to
the legal consequences,
let's compare and contrast some
of the factual differences,
because some of them just jump right out.
First of all, at the time
of this particular scandal,
Hillary Clinton was a government employee.
In fact, she was Secretary of State,
just a few rungs below the
president of the United States.
She was conducting government business
at the highest levels.
She had an active security clearance,
and she had communications
with other people
who had security clearances to
view the classified documents
and classified information,
and she was conducting government business
on a private server, which she absolutely
should not have been doing,
and ironically, was a violation
of the PRA, the Presidential Records Act,
and while there's no doubt
that classified material got
mixed in, by all accounts,
this was an inadvertent mishandling.
In contrast, Donald Trump is not currently
a government employee.
He doesn't have any
security clearances at all.
He was not communicating with people
with security clearances.
In fact, we don't know who
had access to these documents.
Odds are none of these
people had the kinds
of clearances required, and we don't know
to whom these documents were transmitted
or had access to them,
and while it's possible
that Trump's possession of
these government documents
started out as an inadvertent,
it appears clear that, at
some point down the chain,
it was intentional and conscious
to withhold these documents
from being returned to the government.
There's also a volume
in number difference.
In Trump's case, we're
talking about hundreds
of classified documents,
potentially thousands or tens
of thousands of pages
of classified material.
We can tell from the photographs
that many, if not all,
of these documents are
clearly marked as classified
or top secret versus a
comparatively small amount,
in the case of Hillary
Clinton, you have 113 emails
that contain classified information,
only three of which were
marked as confidential,
and while it wouldn't change
the underlying culpability,
there was a big difference in
how the situation was
handled once discovered.
Hillary Clinton cooperated
with the DOJs investigation.
It doesn't appear that Hillary
Clinton ever represented
that everything had been turned
over when it clearly hadn't.
In comparison, Donald Trump, it seems,
consciously hid the documents,
refused to turn it over,
and lied to investigators,
but just because the situation
is different doesn't mean
that Hillary Clinton should
not have been prosecuted.
So let's talk about the charge
that she received preferential treatment.
On July 5th, 2016, FBI
Director, James Comey,
held a press conference
where he made the following statement.
- Although we did not find clear evidence
that Secretary Clinton or
her colleagues intended
to violate laws governing the handling
of classified information,
there is evidence
that they were extremely
careless in their handling
of very sensitive, highly
classified information.
- So was Comey's statement
that no reasonable prosecutor
would bring a case correct or
evidence of political bias?
Well, in 2016, the FBI told
the Senate Judiciary Committee
that, quote, "extremely careless,"
was Comey's common sense way
of describing the actions
of Clinton and her colleagues
and was not intended
to describe the legal
standard for gross negligence
under the Espionage Act,
but Trump and his supporters have argued
if Clinton was indeed extremely careless
with the classified materials,
the failure to prosecute her,
at least for grossly
mishandling classified material
under the Espionage Act, was
a miscarriage of justice,
but it's not enough to
look at the statute.
We have to look at how
prosecutors have brought charges
under this section.
Now back in 2016, Andrew
Torrez, the lawyer
and host of the podcast,
Opening Arguments,
which is excellent,
researched all prosecutions
under the Espionage Act,
and out of 240 cases,
Torrez only found nine
cases that have been brought
under the gross negligence
part of the statute,
and in all of those
gross negligence cases,
the defendant was found
to have made, quote,
"a deliberate decision to
hide or destroy information
"that the defendant knew to
be confidential and improperly
"in his possession."
Torrez concluded that Comey's statement
that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring a case
against Clinton was
correct, write-in quote,
"I can find no case anywhere
in which any person has ever
"been sentenced under the
Espionage Act without evidence
"that said person
unambiguously knew the material
"that they were removing was confidential.
"Since that fact is not present here,
"I conclude that Hillary
Clinton received no special
"treatment when the government
declined to indict her."
- We're talking about 18 U.S.C. 793.
That's the Espionage Act.
It is the same law, with some
amendments, that was used
to prosecute Julius and Ethel Rosenberg.
Virtually all of the
prosecutions under it are for
what we typically think of as spy stuff,
someone with access to
documents that relate
to the national defense,
steals or makes a copy
of those documents, and prosecutors
don't even have to prove
that person ever sold it
to a hostile foreign power
or another spy.
You just have to prove that
they took the document.
You could infer that they
weren't gonna do anything good
with it, and while espionage
no longer carries the death
penalty, it is a felony with
a 10 year maximum sentence,
and that's why we never find any cases
that are even a close analog
to Secretary Clinton's conduct.
It isn't espionage.
When someone leaves a file
cabinet or a door unlocked
or leaves a top secret
document out on their desk.
That's certainly extremely careless,
but those cases aren't
considered espionage,
and you probably noticed I used
the weasel word, virtually.
Virtually all the prosecutions
under the Espionage Act are
for spy stuff, but what about the ones,
the handful, that aren't?
Consider US v Gonzalez.
This involved an Air Force staff sergeant,
who was stationed in Anchorage,
Alaska and was taken off
to go party with his buddy,
who worked for an oil company.
Sarge grabbed a bunch of his
stuff to give to his buddy
and while doing so,
accidentally grabbed two
classified documents.
When he got to Prudho Bay,
he discovered his mistake,
but instead of calling his
superior and owning up to it,
he told his buddy, "Hey,
man, I'm just gonna stick
"these two documents in your desk,
"and totally, make sure you
remind me before I leave
"to take them back with me
to the Air Force base, okay?"
For whatever reason, use your imagination,
the Sarge and his buddy
totally spaced on the documents
and just left them there in the desk.
That might not have been such a big deal
except that the buddy didn't
actually have his own desk.
He shared it with another guy named Nick,
and Nick got to work Monday morning,
opened up his desk drawer,
saw the bright red confidential
sticker on the cover sheet
of the two documents, and
freaked out, as you do.
He called his boss, his
boss called the Air Force,
and one thing led to
another, Sarge was sentenced
to 43 days of confinement, a
little less than the 10 years,
discharged for bad
conduct, reduced in rank,
or consider US v Gaffney,
which coincidentally involved
another Air Force staff
sergeant, although, this guy
would never ever trek
off to Northern Alaska
for a weekend long bender.
No, this guy was a good family man.
He just wanted to spend more time at home
with his pregnant wife, and so he did,
but one of sarges job duties was
to shred classify documents,
and being that this was 1982,
shredders were super slow.
Rather than spending
hours shredding documents
like a dumbbell, he did what anybody
with a pregnant wife might
do, grabbed all the documents,
then deposited them in a nearby
dumpster, problem solved,
but except that helicopter
parenting wouldn't be invented
for two decades.
So kids played in dumpsters all the time.
Some rugrat found the
documents, took them home,
daddy found them under the bed,
hey, could have been worse,
and called the Air Force.
All of these cases that don't quite fit
into the spy stuff category are like this.
They're cases in which the
defendant absolutely knew
that they had compromised
documents in their possession
and then they still did the stupid thing,
and then they tried to
actively cover their tracks.
As Jim Comey put it, "All of
the cases prosecuted involve
"some combination of clearly intentional
"and willful mishandling
of classified information,"
the very behavior for
which Secretary Clinton
was exonerated.
- But look, don't take
legal advice from a podcast.
Take legal advice from a YouTube channel,
but why would prosecutors
only bring cases involving
deliberate conduct when
the statute requires
only gross negligence?
Well, that's because the
gross negligent statute
might be unconstitutionally vague.
Under the vagueness doctrine,
statutes that are vague,
indefinite, or uncertain
violate due process,
because such laws fail to give
the individual proper notice
of how to conform their
conduct to follow the law,
and in a case called Gorin
versus the United States,
the Supreme Court suggested
that the then operative provisions
that the Espionage Act was
not unconstitutionally vague,
only because it criminalized
intentional conduct, quote,
"The obvious delimiting words
in the statute are those
"requiring intent or reason to
believe that the information
"to be obtained is to
be used to the injury
"of the United States, which
requires those prosecuted
"to have acted in bad faith."
And in an August 16th, 2016
letter explaining the decision
not to bring the charges,
the FBI told the Senate
Judiciary Committee
that the DOJ had only prosecuted
for intentional mishandling
of documents, because the
gross negligence language
is likely unconstitutional.
They said, quote, "There are concerns
"about the constitutional implications
"of criminalizing
grossly negligent conduct
"without requiring the government to prove
"that the person knew he or
she was doing something wrong."
The letter noted that only
one person in 99 years
had been charged with
mishandling classified documents
in a grossly negligent way,
a charge that was dismissed
when the defendant pleaded guilty
to making false statements.
So given the potential unconstitutionality
of gross negligence
prosecutions, the DOJ has opted
to almost exclusively
prosecute cases involving
only intentional misconduct,
but is Trump subject
to an unfair double
standard by law enforcement?
Well, so far, legal experts
are pretty much unanimous
that Trump's case is much, much worse,
and it's not subject to a double standard.
As more information about the
FBI search has been released,
legal experts have weighed in
on whether Trump has been treated unfairly
when compared to Clinton.
David Laufman, who headed
the Justice Department's
counterintelligence section until 2018,
said there's simply no comparison
between Clinton's emails
and the judge approved
search of Mar-a-Lago, quote,
"People sling these cases around
"to suit their political agenda,
"but every case has to stand
on its own circumstances.
"For the department to
pursue a search warrant
"in Mar-a-Lago tells me
that the quantum and quality
"of the evidence they were
reciting in a search warrant,
"an affidavit that an FBI agent swore to,
"was likely so pulverizing in its force
"as to eviscerate any notion
that the search warrant
"and this investigation
is politically motivated."
And Laufman has experience in this area.
Not only did he personally
oversee the investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails,
he also managed the investigation
into David Petraeus,
and here's a quick summary of what led
to the FBI getting a search warrant
to recover classified documents
and presidential records
from Trump's residence at Mar-a-Lago.
When Trump left office in
January, 2021 boxes of records
that his White House counsel
said should have gone
to the National Archives
were, instead, shipped
to Trump's residence at Mar-a-Lago.
Officials at the National
Archives spent eight months
in negotiations with Trump
to return the documents.
15 documents were
returned in January, 2022.
Upon reviewing the documents, though,
NARA saw documents clearly
marked classified intermingled
with non-classified info
resulting in a referral to the DOJ
to investigate possible
mishandling of classified material.
The FBI had evidence that
dozens of additional boxes
with classified info were
still being kept at Mar-a-Lago.
So the DOJ obtained a grand
jury subpoena seeking documents
bearing classification markings
that were still in Trump's possession.
On June 3rd, Trump's
custodian of records turned
over additional boxes to the DOJ,
then signed a certification
swearing that a diligence search
had been done and all
responsive documents produced.
Trump's lawyer told the
FBI agents that all boxes
of classified records had been kept
in a secure storage room.
However, the FBI uncovered
multiple sources of evidence
that the response to the grand
jury subpoena was incomplete
and the classified documents
were still on site.
The FBI also had evidence that, quote,
"government records were
likely concealed and removed
"from the storage room and
that efforts were likely taken
"to obstruct the
government's investigation."
So it's against this backdrop
over a year of delays
in returning all classified
documents voluntarily not
turning over documents in
response to the subpoena
and evidence of obstruction of justice
that the government finally
got a search warrant
for Mar-a-Lago and conducted the search.
Of course, we got more
information on August 18th, 2022
when Judge Bruce Reinhardt,
the magistrate overseeing
the Mar-a-Lago search,
unsealed the warrant cover
sheet revealing the FBI was
investigating potential
violations of 18 U.S.C. 793,
willful retention of
National Defense Information,
18 U.S.C. 2071, concealment or removal
of government records, and 18 U.S.C. 1519,
obstruction of a federal investigation.
Clinton was also investigated
for violating Section 2071,
but Bradley Moss, a well-respected lawyer
who handles national security cases,
said that that cases of Clinton
and Trump are significantly
different given Trump's willful
retention of classified documents, quote,
"Trump took properly marked
hard copy classified documents
"from the White House,
shipped them to Florida,
"and stored them in an unsecured
location at his residence."
Moss also noted that,
while some Trump documents
were clearly marked as classified,
the presence of classified information
in Clinton's emails was
less obvious, quote,
"The emails were never
marked as classified,
"because there were communications
"from unclassified government accounts."
And similarly, the FBI's August,
2016 letter justifying its
decision not to charge Clinton.
The bureau noted how past
prosecutions involved some
combination of clearly intentional
and willful mishandling
of classified info, significant quantities
of classified info exposed
to support an inference
of intent, or indications of disloyalty
to the United States,
none of which were present
with Clinton.
As examples, the FBI
cited past prosecutions
of ex-CIA Director, David Petreius,
who knowingly exposed
significant classified materials
to his biographer turned mistress
and then lied about it when confronted.
Former Bill Clinton National
Security Advisor, Sandy Berger,
who stole clearly marked
classified documents
from the National Archives
by hiding them in his clothes
and Afghanistan Naval
Reservist, Bryan Nishimura,
who removed hundreds of
clearly classified documents
from classified US military
information systems,
lied to investigators about them,
and then destroyed large
quantities of classified documents.
Contrasting these cases
with the Clinton case,
the FBI highlighted Clinton
received three emails containing
C-markings for confidential
and that that wasn't clear
evidence of knowledge
or criminal intent.
As further evidence of
lack of criminal intent,
the FBI highlighted that
Clinton did not originate
this information, but rather
the email chains were forwarded
by staff members with the
confidential markings buried deep
in the email threads.
The DOJ's 2018 report on
Clinton's emails also concluded
that the classification
markings were not clear.
In addition, over 2,000
emails were retroactively
characterized as including
classified information,
which underscores the
uncertainty regarding the status
of Clinton's emails.
In Trump's case, the ex-president
was explicitly notified,
not only that he was
illegally in possession
of highly classified
documents, but the DOJ
and intelligence community had concerns
that those classified items
were not safely stored.
According to the Wall Street
Journal, an individual familiar
with the boxes from NARA
had alerted investigators
the documents were not
being stored securely,
which heightened the agency's urgency
to seize the documents.
In the May 10th, 2022 letter,
NARA informed Trump's attorneys
that the boxes recovered
from Mar-a-Lago in January
contained more than 700 pages
of classified material,
including documents marked,
"extremely sensitive",
and after reports from inside Mar-a-Lago
that individuals were seen
moving boxes in and out
of the room, in June of 2022,
the DOJ subpoenaed the Trump organization
for Mar-a-Lago security
footage of the area.
Since the search, the government
has recovered more than 300
documents with classified markings,
and according to the
partially unsealed affidavit
that gave rise to the search warrant,
NARA referred the matter to the DOJ
for investigation following
a preliminary review
of 15 boxes of documents.
Nara warn the DOJ the classified
documents were haphazardly
mixed with, quote, "newspapers, magazines,
"and printed news articles,
among other items."
Of most significant concern to NARA,
the classified records
were unfoldered, intermixed
with other records, and
otherwise improperly identified.
These fears were confirmed when agents
who searched Mar-a-Lago found,
quote, "highly sensitive
"and classified documents
lying in unsecured places
"outside the storage room
that the Justice Department
"officials had earlier
asked to be better secured."
When the FBI conducted a
preliminary review of 15 boxes
that Trump finally turned
over to NARA in May of 2022,
the agency discovered that
Trump was in possession
of at least, quote, "184 unique documents
"with classified markings,
including 67 documents marked
"as confidential, 92
documents marked as secret,
"and 25 documents marked as top secret."
- If you're the president
of the United States,
you can declassify just by
saying it's declassified,
even by thinking about it.
- The affidavit further
alleges that the return boxes
include classified
documents related to, quote,
"clandestine human sources,
"who help US intelligence
gathering, as well as
"how it conducts foreign surveillance
"and information under lawful
domestic surveillance."
These are some of America's
most closely held secrets
and disclosure of this
information could lead
to sources being compromised or killed,
and the intermingling of personal papers
with these highly classified documents,
as well as their location
in, what is reported
to be the former
president's personal desk,
all go to state of mind, and
that former President Trump
may have intentionally
kept these documents
and been actively reviewing them long
after they were requested
by the government.
- Presidents leave.
They take things.
They take documents,
They read them.
- Clinton was comparatively
more cooperative
with the DOJs investigation of her server
than Trump has been with
his classified documents,
which forced the DOJ to be
more aggressive with Trump.
Clinton critics would likely dispute
such a characterization, though,
noting that 30,000
emails were deleted weeks
after Clinton received a
congressional subpoena,
though, the deletion was apparently
by an unidentified server employee.
Clinton defenders would counter
that she did voluntarily turn
over her private email server
to the DOJ in August of 2015,
and the following month,
the FBI was able to recover
many of the deleted emails.
Clinton also voluntarily
met with the FBI for a three
and a half hour interview
on July 3rd, 2016.
In contrast, Trump was
vehemently opposed to turning
over the documents voluntarily,
even in response to a government subpoena,
which is why a search warrant
was apparently required
to get the documents back.
The redacted affidavit alleges
that NARA began making requests
for the documents return
in May of 2021, and it
took eight months of delay
before Team Trump informed NARA
that there were boxes to be recovered.
On August 16th, 2022, the New
York Times detailed additional
efforts by the FBI to
recover NARA's documents,
and the article highlights
how Trump blew off demands
to have the documents returned,
telling several advisors,
quote, "It's not theirs, it's mine."
Now, if you'd like to hear
more about the legal misfortune
about people in the Trump orbit,
you can watch an entire
exclusive video we did
about Steve Bannon's upcoming fraud trial.
That's the one where he got pardoned,
but then New York State
went after him anyway,
and it's a question of whether
double jeopardy applies,
but I'm sorry to tell you that
that exclusive video is really exclusive,
and you can't watch it on YouTube,
but you can see it with today's
sponsor, Curiosity Stream
and Nebula, because on
Nebula, my videos always come
out early with zero ads, and
I release exclusive content
all the time, like that
exclusive Steve Bannon video
or entire video about the
legal stories that are not safe
for work and are too hot for YouTube,
as well as Things Misunderstand
about the Constitution,
why NFTs are bad for creators,
and my first full length
documentary, Bad Law Works Good,
and even though this
exclusive content is exclusive
to Nebula, you can get
access to it for free
with Curiosity Stream,
and it's not just me.
Nebula is creator-owned
and creator-operated.
There's exclusive content
released every single day,
multiple times every
single day, and by the way,
we've been developing Nebula like crazy.
It now has apps for iOS,
Android, Apple TV, Roku, Fire TV,
and Android TV, and was recently nominated
for its first Streamy, and we're thrilled
that Nebula is partnering
with Curiosity Stream,
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the thousands
of titles on Curiosity Stream.
Now, the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of the incredible content is
through the amazing Curiosity
Stream, Nebula Bundle deal
with this current sales price
of less than $15 per year
to get access to both
sites, and to be clear,
that Nebulous subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a
better deal in streaming
where you get access to
two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch and enjoy
all for less than $15 per year
at the current sales price,
and what's more, signing up
will actually help countless
independent educational creators
beyond just Legal Eagle.
So sign up right now by click
on the button that's on screen
right now or down below
in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and tons of exclusive
content that you'll love.
So click on the link
that's on screen right now,
and after that, click
on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.